The prevailing alternative and the one that is
used in most operational networks today is link state
routing. In link state routing, each node distributes
a network map to every other node in the
network. And then, each node performs a shortest
path computation between itself and all other nodes in
the network. So initially, each node adds the cost
of its immediate neighbors, D(v), and every other distance
to a node that is infinite. Then each node floods the cost between nodes u and v
to all of its neighbors. And the distance to
any node v becomes the minimum of the cost
between u and w plus the cost to w. Or the current shortest path to v. The
shortest path computation is often called the dijkstra, shortest
path ROUTING ALGORITHM. Two common link state routing protocol
are open shortest paths first or OSPF and
intermediate system - intermediate system or IS-IS. In
recent years, IS-IS has gained increasing use in
large internet service providers and is the more
commonly used. Link state routing protocol in large
transit networks today. One problem with link state
routing is scale. The complexity of a link
state routing protocol grows as n cubed where n
is the number of nodes in the network.